(Louis Hector Chavez): Welcome all.
Welcome to the Google I / O conference, named Louis Hector Chavez
I'm one of the engineers in the Chrome OS team.
You may have seen the announcement made earlier today
We're bringing Android apps to Chromebooks.
Bravo
So I'm very excited to be here,
Because I can finally tell you what we were working on
In recent months.
So it is no longer a secret anymore.
Well, first
Let's talk a bit about why we did this,
And why it should be of interest to you.
First, Chrome OS is a growing platform.
While PC shipments are decreasing,
The Chrome OS continues to grow.
In fact, last year we achieved an annual increase of 32%.
These figures are continuing to improve in certain sectors.
For example, Chromebooks are the first
In primary and secondary education in the United States.
There are millions of active users,
With more than 50 different devices from 13 original manufacturers in 44 countries,
We have more amazing Chromebooks on the way.
Well if, we have a large and growing platform
With a large number of potential new users.
Here comes your turn as an Android developer.
All Android developers want more users.
All Chromebook users want more apps,
But they do not want any application.
They want the applications they know and like.
So we believe that bringing Android apps to your Chrombooks
Provides a compromise that helps both groups of people.
Well, if a developer wants to bring it to a Chromebook,
What choices are available?
Let's start with the possibility that there is no solution.
You can write a Chrome OS app.
This means writing your app twice.
This requires learning a new platform,
Which may produce a more original application,
But it requires a lot of work.
A lot of maintenance,
Requiring the retention of two separate code bases.
So it is not an option for most people.
Another option is to build an HTML5 app.
This may result in an application that looks native to Chrome OS,
But you need an Android HTML program,
That does not seem very original.
It also does not benefit well
From the primary Android system.
So it is not a great choice either.
Chrome Runtime ARC was another choice.
We've released this in the Chrome OS team,
Two years ago in 2014 as a way to launch Android apps
On Chromebooks.
We're running full Android cases
In Native Client protection mode.
Unfortunately it had some challenges for developers.
Access to some system resources,
It was limited by the advanced structure
Defines native client protection.
For example, we had to do a complete file system simulation
Because it was not available to us.
Some applications did not work well with it.
Native Client has a single execution model,
Causing some applications to not work well,
Especially the Google Play store.
Finally, some of the developers' delimiters,
Such as in-app payments,
It required more work on your part.
After all this,
We still believe that making Android apps work,
As native native Chrome OS applications,
Is the right idea, so we have made many improvements,
We are building a whole new platform,
To run Android apps on Chromebooks.
Well, many of you may have missed
View the demonstration day, so I will
One is shorter now.
Well, first, this is the standard Chrome OS desktop.
But you can see that we now have a Play Store.
Bravo.
Of course I do not have Internet.
So there's no Play Store.
But fortunately I installed some applications
Such as Gmail.
Surprise.
If one of the things we do here
Is that we have support for multiple windows.
Not only that, but we can change the window size.
We can also grow up, and things like that.
Stylish things.
We also support integration with some native Chrome notifications.
For example:
"Hello world!"
And of course, as I mentioned before I do not have Internet,
So we will miss this.
Here it is.
If we see, we have an Internet Offline login in Android apps now.
Well go back to the slides.
We've seen what it really looks like.
So let's talk a bit more about how to implement.
First, we no longer use the Native Client anymore.
We use a completely new protection mechanism.
Using existing Linux namespaces,
To separate Android and Chrome OS.
It's already used in the Chrome OS,
And in some of our cloud offerings.
We use the namespace of the download, processing, user and network,
And the IPC name space.
Basic protection team developed new features
For this.
Android works directly
On the Linux kernel, this has increased the surface of the attack
A little more than we like it,
The Chrome OS protection team has developed a new way to add
Alternative syscall tables.
This is more effective and orderly
Of the connection filtering technologies currently on the system.
Such as seccomp-bpf which by the way he developed
Chrome OS Protection Team.
Android and Chrome OS
Their own configuration will make everything slower,
So we have a shared configuration model, where there is a component
One comprehensive.
This makes things faster and more responsive.
Finally, where we know that the goal of a lot of developers
For ARM processor only, we provide simultaneous binary translation,
So that their applications become the custom menu for the ARM processor
Playable on x86 devices such as Google Chromebook Pixel
Without any additional work on your part.
If this new method still maintains a high level
Of security in both operating systems.
Where you can keep all security features in the Chrome operating system
Such as verified root, encrypted user data and persistent updates.
Android has existing Linux properties.
There are no visible devices or simulations,
So you get full native performance.
Finally, as we are running the entire Android system,
You can run Android Marshmallow entirely through Chrome OS.
This includes the Google Play store.
So part of what we learned from Chrome's Runtime application,
Is that integration is important.
Whenever applications are integrated with the rest of the operating system,
The more their shape and performance the better.
If we do not give Android direct access
Equipment only in limited areas.
And the rest of the time, the equipment remains
Under Chrome OS.
But even so, we had a lot of integration points
In order for Android developers to still call the same APIs,
The APIs beneath it will call the Chrome OS.
This allows both operating systems,
With the same perspective of the system
Rather than having separate binoculars.
Well, what does all this translate,
What impact does it have on your apps?
Since we're running a full Android system,
This means that most applications can
Turn on Chrome OS without any change in scripts at all.
Of course, since this is a new platform,
You may want to make some improvements,
Simple adjustments.
But your app works as a Chrome OS app.
Most things you expect the Android system to do
Chrome OS will now be saved instead of being restricted
With a small window.
Each task runs in its own window.
You get Android alerts along with their Chrome OS counterparts.
There is one app launcher in the shelf.
The login information will be shared
Between operating systems so that you do not have to sign in twice.
You can also share files in the Downloads folder.
The equipment is also integrated where you can get in touch
Wi-Fi and Bluetooth.
The camera, microphone, audio and video are also working.
All input mechanisms in Chrome OS
Remain integrated through the application,
So the keyboard and touchpad events will
Are connected to your app,
As well as touch events if your Chromebook supports them.
Meanwhile, your application is still
Works as an Android app.
Since we're running a full Android stack,
The Marshmallow API is available to you.
This includes Google Play services.
So things like in-app payments
They will be available in Chromebooks for the consumer.
As we will not add any new APIs,
So there is nothing to learn this time.
All system services work,
And all interactions between the system services and your application
Are exactly as you expect.
This includes things such as application lifecycle events.
Finally, the equipment is called,
You do not need to worry about anything.
I will be clear, while the applications can
To run on Chrome OS, we still need to
Chrome OS users agree to use this feature.
We understand that there are scenarios where people do not want to
To do so yet.
We also provide users from educational institutions,
Additional policies can enforce if and which applications can work
On the devices they manage.
Well, when does this become available?
For you as developers, we will do that
On Chrome OS 53.
This should be available on Dev Channel in June,
And 53 should be generally available
For all users in the fixed channel in September,
So you still have some time to get ready.
We will start with the support of three devices, the Asus 10-inch Flip
And Acer Chromebook R11
And Chromebook Pixel 2015.
We will support more hardware gradually
During the next major events so continue to follow us.
This is the URL where you can inspect
Any devices will be supported in any version.
So follow us.
Well, it's great that most applications will work
Outside the box without any changes in the node,
But take a look at best practices
Which can be taken into account in order for your app to work
Much better on Chromebooks.
There's a wide variety of shape factors in your Chromebook.
All have an actual keyboard and a touchpad.
Most of the devices we will provide support
It also has a touch screen.
Some are so convertible that they can
Switch between shape factors for laptop and tablet computer.
While we test applications, most of them are
We found it worked very well
With keyboard and mouse.
However, they did not all work.
It is therefore advisable that you as developers
Take the test with a keyboard and a mouse.
And also where basically there is new equipment available to you
Why not benefit from it as much as possible.
If the productivity applications can support
Such as Quick Launch Keys.
This will make users more productive.
Some games even adjust themselves to control them
Using the keyboard and mouse.
Well, now to the important part in the coding.
By default, all Android apps
Touch screen equipment is required.
Now, I've mentioned before that not all Chromebooks
It will provide a touch screen.
So it is very important in the AndroidManifest.xml file
That specifies the android.hardware.touchscreen property
To be not required.
This will allow the application to appear
In the Play Store on all Chromebooks
Instead of Chromebooks that only support the touch screen.
If you exit this presentation with one command
In your mind, let it be.
Well, best practices for multiple windows.
On the laptop, everyone uses multiple windows
For productivity assuming there is more
Pixels are available on the screen.
Now, I mentioned several times before
We support Marshmallow API interface,
Marshallow has no programming interfaces for multiple windows.
I also mentioned that we will not add new APIs.
So how does it work?
In order to reduce the amount of work required of all,
We will only support some schemes
Which your app probably supports.
First, we have a horizontal scheme.
This is the default schema.
This uses the aspect ratio to the Nexus 9.
We also support a vertical layout that works just like Nexus 5.
We also have magnifying windows
Which takes all the pixels available in the screen.
Finally for the convertible devices
We have a touch mode which is much like placing a zoom,
But it hides window decoration and bottom shelf,
So it's similar to the expanded Android mode.
We added some window controls to switch between all
Available Charts.
This allows both users and developers
By choosing the appropriate balance of information density
In the sizes and schemes in which their applications were originally designed.
Now some things you should take into consideration.
As in the application of multiple windows in the system N
We will not change the application lifecycle model.
Specifically one application will be in the onResume state,
This is the current window.
And all remaining windows and applications
Are in the case of onPause.
The memory access prevention mechanism is also integrated
With the rest of the operating system,
And take into account the z-order of the windows
When calculating the final assessment.
So that applications that have been used less recently
Will stop first.
Well where to change direction
Also changes the size of the window in your device,
You need to tell the right direction for your Android screen
So that you use only the direction you support.
Now, it is also important
Read this document for Handle Runtime Changes
In official Android documentation.
There will be things you do not expect it to be
Will change wherever the trend changes.
For example the width and length of the screen
They will change in ways you do not necessarily expect
It is on normal devices
It changes only between them, and here
You can have completely different values.
Also DPI density settings can be changed
When the trend is turned.
And also, it is important - make sure to cancel any resources
For cache.
Because that's what the trend has changed
You are actually changing the device,
You must be careful to load the right resources
After changing direction.
Now these two things are important for Android N,
So you'd better do them now.
Also use the correct correlations for tasks.
As explained in the presentation it is possible for a task
To launch another activity in a new mission.
This will display a new window.
But if you intend to have a conditional window,
You must put that activity in the same task.
Otherwise the errors will reach the application
You did not expect it.
Finally, consider the onPaused state.
While your app is paused,
It is still visible, so be careful not to
No display works because it is
It may seem strange to the user.
It will also consume a lot of battery.
Use and recover backups effectively
Is very important.
One of the most important features of Chromebooks
Is that users can simply get rid of their devices and buy new ones,
They register entry, all their applications and their numbers
Will be present.
So it is not a very necessary condition to support backups and recover them,
But it is a very good idea and users will love it.
Make sure you read the official documents
About Backup & Restore.
There are also some scenarios where Chromebooks are
Share between a large number
Of users.
For example in education,
Students do not have personal Chromebooks
Where they are shared by students.
So if you are writing an application for educational purposes
Be sure to take that scenario into account
Be aware of the local storage you are using.
In general, Chromebooks support fewer sensors
Compared to mobile devices.
For example, most Android developers
They are used to having a GPS device for accurate location information.
Chromebooks do not have a GPS device,
But she still has access
On location information using Wi-Fi.
This may be enough to find out the best restaurants around you,
But it may not be enough to just take a Chromebook
Then put it in your car and expect to get directions to move around step by step.
If you are advised to be careful not to ask for equipment
May not be available.
Of course if your application
Requires a hardware that
Not available on Chromebooks We'll take your decision into consideration
We will not show that app in the Play Store for Chromebooks.
There are some code properties
Which we will not support in Chrome OS.
We want users to have an integrated Chrome OS experience,
The applications will allocate some parts of the user interface
Will not be available.
Applications that provide custom input devices and widgets for applications
Live screen backgrounds or home screens will not be supported.
Chrome OS will also be the device manager for Android,
So the applications you declare are
Manage the device or users
Will not be supported.
We will initially ship to Android Marshmallow
But it is a good idea to focus some effort on modernization
To N in the end because you will bring
Lots of properties that will improve
Productivity desktop users.
For example you will be able to
Resize all activities instead of being
Bound in one of the four schemes
Which we now support.
You will also be able to use drag and drop between applications.
There will be a new API for the mouse pointer and available.
So in order to know more about N,
You can see these two presentations
Which were broadcast yesterday and today here in I / O,
"What's New in Android" and "Multi-Window Mode"
You can also view the official Android N preview documentation.
Well, if you have more questions about this
Official documents may be used
For Android apps on Chromebooks.
You can also ask questions at Stack Overflow
Or post questions on the Android G + Community.
Now before I leave, many of you have tried
Access the early day announcement
But they could not reach it, so ..
We will return the offer we made early today.
If here is Katie that will offer you the previous offer.
<Applause>.
(Katy): Well thank you so much Louis.
(Lewis): Can we change the offer?
(Katy): Well, very good.
If we apologize to you this morning because the place was a little tight.
So we decided with a few extra minutes,
To bring back your offer.
So unfortunately, the secondary delivery will be a little different.
Hope to be better.
But here we have Pixel 2.
Looks like a regular Chromebook.
We have a Chrome browser here.
But it is clear that you now have a Play Store on the shelf here.
So we will advance and occupy it.
So here we can actually review our applications.
This looks a lot like the normal Play Store, so let's move forward
And prove something.
So I thought we had decided that Bejeweled was a very good game.
To look for them and to progress and prove them.
Look at this.
By chance, it seems that the wife was
She asks me to make a poster for my daughter's birthday party.
And as a good employee I will come forward
"I'm glad about that.
The great thing about how we integrated Android
Is that we get a nice internal response that
You expect it on your tablets and phones,
So I will forward and send this now.
Great.
So, let's go ahead and do this.
You already installed Photoshop Mix from the Play Store,
So I will come forward and occupy it now.
If this is indeed a picture of a daughter he was,
I think the doll is fed a little.
It's strange.
Anyway, I was told it
It would be more appropriate to put ice cream here instead.
So I'll come forward and try to find some ice cream here.
If fortunately from Adobe stock they have ..
Some wonderful pictures of ice cream.
It's actually very strange, like half a napolean ice cream
With some pistachios.
But it looks a little big, so we did not advance
We can use touch screen
Just as we expect.
We can progress and miniaturize ice cream.
This is a little better than the pen I think.
One of the problems here is obvious now
That the biscuit over her hand,
So we will progress and lack this.
We can round up more and more little.
We can advance and use the touch screen.
That was a piece we did not want.
We will advance and ...
- Here it is. -> Applause.
This live use of Photoshop is not my best work.
<Applause>
Most likely will appear in my next performance evaluation,
But no problem let's go ahead and keep this anyway.
Well we keep it.
This sounds great.
If I'm told he wants a poster, so I will
Open Word for this.
The really nice thing about this is that I can now start
I have normal Word here, I put some pictures
For Lian's birthday.
there he is.
This sounds very good.
If now I want to bring this back to his wife.
So let's move forward and we can press that we want
Share this as an attachment.
Come on, open Gmail.
We heard it was a very good product.
We go forward and send this to Nan.
This sounds great.
Let's go forward and send this.
What do we know?
By chance one of them attacks me on Clash of Clans.
So again, how we've integrated the Android structure
Chat has become operational.
This is a martyr here.
We will move forward .. It would be nice to inspect our village.
If Clash of Clans.
We will move forward and close Photoshop.
We no longer need it.
Let's make Clash of Clans work with us.
Oh my God.
They have never seen a show that does not work on stage.
We will progress .. We have a slight error known here.
Anyway, we will move forward and continue from this.
I apologize here.
Another great game is Clash of Clans,
What I like most is Galaxy on Fire.
Here we can use the desktop GPU.
Everything is very smooth.
I do not know if it sounds too tired to you
In attendance but in any case very good performance here too.
However, I can also purchase in-app.
So I can go straight and go to buy extras.
I offer and press buy.
Now this will be available on my phone ...
The payment process worked .. great and on my tablet too.
If again, this was just a quick look at what we did too
By showing it this morning.
We are, of course, very excited to work with you all
To bring your apps to Chromebooks.
So thank you very much.
<Applause>
(Lewis): Well that's all we have.
Enjoy the rest of the show.
If you have any questions to ask in the Spaces app,
Or we will stay with you on stage.
thank you.
Good-bye.